[Musique]
bonjour François baayerou bonjour
bonjour En plein remanimement vous avez
annoncé hier soir à nos confrères de la
FP faute d'accord profond sur la
politique à suivre je n'entrerai pas au
gouvernement qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
bah il s'est passé que depuis des jours
et des jours comme vous l'avez vu depuis
que dans le procès injuste qui nous
était fait nous avons obtenu une relaxe
j'ai obtenu une relax et plusieurs des
nôtres euh le le le bruit la rumeur
avait couru que je pourrais entrer au
gouvernement euh
et
cette rumeur là elle s'accompagnait
naturellement d'une orientation
politique c'est ça entré au gouvernement
euh et cette orientation politique
elle m'entraînait ou en tout cas elle
exigeait de moi que je prenne un des
secteurs que je considère le plus en
crise du pays lequel il y a deux
secteurs que je considère dans une crise
de toute la France est dans enfin tout
le pays est dans une crise grave on
n'est pas les seuls tous les pays
occidentaux tous les pays européens sont
dans une crise de cet ordre pu pour moi
il y a deux secteurs qui sont
incroyablement
significatifs de cette perte de
confiance que nous traversons le premier
de ces secteurs c'est l'éducation
nationale euhù vous voyez que
euh année après année
euh les enseignants les parents d'élèves
les profs se désespèrent et les
résultats chiffrés montrent qu'il y a
une perte de confiance qu'il y a un
décrochage que euh et les et les
enseignants pour eux vivent ça euh euh
d'une manière un peu désabusé désespéré
il y a les deux et une ministre à ou
estag et j'étais persuadé qu'on peut
redresser l'éducation nationale en peu
d'années mais que ça demande un choix
politique qui est de faire ça avec les
enseignants et les autres parties
prenantes de l'école pardon mais c'est
pas le cas de la personne qui sera
nommée non mais vous vous voyez bien on
est on est sur un fond
de de une musique de fond qui est au
fond les enseignants travaille pas assez
euh c'est ce que vous a dit le président
de la République c'est ce que vous avez
dit Gabriel Attal mais Gabriel Atal a
fixé des orientation et et et je pense
que ça ça méritait euh une une
clarification pour moi en tout cas
l'éducation nationale ça ne peut pas se
redresser dans un climat uniquement
gestionnaire on va dire com prier
premier secteur oui juste mais pour
qu'on comprenne bien vous vous avez en
quelque sorte candidaté pour le
ministère de l'Éducation pas candidaté
on vous a proposé endu en tout cas lundi
soir on parlait explicitement je n'ai
pas candidaté lundi soir vos confrères
m'ont posé la question et j'ai dit que
pour un secteur du pays aussi important
à mes yeux et dans une crise aussi grave
oui j'étais disponible pour prendre ce
risque présid le Président vous l'a
proposé ce ministère et donc je je
rapporte jamais mes mes conversations
avec le président est-ce que c'est une
question de fond d'orientation politique
ou de nature du poste qui vous était
proposé et qui vous aurait été refusé
non pas du tout c'est une question
sur les deux sujets que je vais évoquer
c'est une
question
d'engagement en face du
pays donc ça c'est le premier sujet il y
a un deuxième sujet qui me préoccupe
terriblement
c'est la
rupture en
France constante
continuelle progressive et de plus en
plus grave entre la base et les pouvoirs
les pouvoir j'embrasse tous les pouvoirs
y compris le pouvoir
médiatique on a vu cette crise en fond
des gilets jaunes on vient de voir cette
crise en fond des
agriculteurs on voit cette crise dans de
nombreux secteurs dans le domaine de la
santé et puis et on a un
gouvernement sans doute composé de
personnalités tout à fait compétentees
ou on espère qu'elles le sont on voit un
gouvernement qui comporte sur 14 11
ministres parisiens ou
franciliens et sur 15 membres du
gouvernement pas un seul du sud de la
Loire et vous vous rendez compte que
tout ça créer un déséquilibre et où les
les gens ceux qui vous écoute nous
écoute il y a un déséquilibre
géographique depuis des mois mais qui
pouvait être qui pouvait être comblé par
par ce ce Reman on est là dans les
ministres de plein exercice après on a
des ministres délégués vous intéressz
c'était l'éducation nationale ou
l'aménagement du territoire
l'aménagement du territoire la réforme
de l'État la simplification du pays les
gens assommé de de questionnaires qui
savent même pas remplir par on a du mal
on a du mal à faire le distingo dans ce
que vous nous dites entre enfin sur
cette question est-ce que c'était une
question de poste ou une question des
accords de
fond c'était une question
d'identification dans le pays de ce qui
va ou de ce qui mérite le plus de soin
et le plus d'engagement h quand vous
avez une crise qui est selon moi aussi
profonde et donct je connais le résultat
et vous le connaissez aussi le résultat
de cette crise de cette incompréhension
euh croissante entre les milieux de
pouvoir et la base des Français et ben
c'est la progression des extrêmes et
singulièrement Front national vous
faites en fait il est pas partagé par
Gabriel Attal et Emmanuel Macron c'est
ce que vous nous dites là ce matin je je
pense qu'il le partag ou qu'ils en
partagent une parti mais vous voyez bien
que la les les actes euh devraient
suivre les paroles et nous euh modem qui
avons particip à l'édification de la
majorité qui en somme un pôle euh euh
reconnu et on on vous présente
d'ailleurs comme un allié historique euh
mais l'allié historique nous
avonsemmanuel Macron euh le modem
Mouvement Démocrate c'est son inquiétude
depuis le début HM nous nous disons euh
attention euh on ne peut pas laisser
progresser comme ça euh ce qui est pour
nous une menace et un risque mais là
quand même François baayerou vous parlez
de désaccord profond politique oui j'ai
parlé de la politique d'éducation c'est
la phrase sur la politique d'éducation
ça faut pas sur l'ensemble de la
politique de gabrielal et du
gouvernement j'espère que non non parce
que c'est important on va avoir
l'occasion d'en reparler j'espère que
non mais vous avez bien vu vous avez
bien vu euh
euh ce que vous avez analysé comme un
déséquilibre politique c'estàd allez-y
c'est-à-dire
avec avec le sentiment qu'il y a
certaine sensibilité de la majorité qui
occupe l'espace et qui déséquilibre
politique devient une crise politique
vous avez 50 51 députés euh
j'essaie de faire
que quand il s'agit de dire
stop il y a une dérive euh le moment est
est venu de de remettre les choses à
l'endroit de rappeler pourquoi nous
sommes là quelle est la qu'est-ce qu'on
a promis au pays en en 2017 euh on a
promis vous souvenez-vous qu'on allait
disait-on entre guillemets gouverner
autrement et hier soir un de nos députés
dans la réunion de groupe a dit écoutez
moi je me suis engagé parce que je
pensais qu'on pouvait gouverner
autrement et j'ai l'impression de plus
en plus qu'on gouverne comme avant
c'est-à-dire que les choix se font dans
des milieux je vous repose la question
tout ça il y a les ingrédients d'une
crise politique c'est-à-dire du fait que
le modem ne pourrait ne plus soutenir à
l'avenir le gouvernement non c'est pas
ce que ce que je dis euh dans le
redressement du pays le modem et
d'autres sont engagés en première ligne
mais ce que je vois moi c'est la
multiplication des indices selon
lesquels la crise on ne va pas le
l'équilibrer on ne va pas
l'arrêter mais on fait comme si elle
n'existait pas or elle existe et nous
avons alors là c'est spécifique à notre
famille politique nous avons une vie
une vision du monde de la société un
projet qui qui en effet sont assez
ambitieux pour s'adresser à ce sujetl
que vous décrivez tous les jours c'est
votre métier tous les jours vous envoyez
on l'a vu avec la crise agricole on va
quand même essayer François de
comprendre ce que vous voulez vraiment
il faut qu'on marque une très courte
pause on va retrouver dans une minute
vous êes avec nous jusqu'à 9h on laisse
passer le fil info puisqu'il est déjà
8h42 sophiech François Baou vous avez
dit hier soir donc je n'entrerai pas au
gouvernement sur la base de désaccords
profond politique vous avez vous n avez
politique sur l'éducation sur
l'éducation au fond quel est votre
problème on essaie de comprendre ce
matin pourquoi cette crise politique
existe aujourd'hui au plus haut sommet
de l'État quel est votre problème est-ce
que vous considérez que le gouvernement
penche trop à droite et qu'Emmanuel
Macron ne vous écoute plus aujourd'hui
je n'aime pas
euh la perpétuelle étiquette droite
gauche si nous avons bâti ce ce ce grand
socle central de la majorité c'est pour
échapper à l'étiquetage à cet étiquetage
là bon alors c'est quoi votre
problème plus on avance dans le temps et
moins on a l'impression que la que la
rupture avec la société avec les gens
qui travaillent avec ceux qui sont à la
retraite avec ceux qui cherchent du
travail ou ceux qui n'y sont pas encore
plus on a l'impression que cette rupture
s'aggrave et cette rupture elle doit
être pour la combattre il faut
avoir une une vision qui embrasse tout
le pays et pas seulement le monde des
pouvoirs dans lequel nous sommes je suis
persuadé qu'on ne peut pas résoudre les
problèmes de l'éducation nationale
puisque c'est deux qu'on parlit sans le
faire avec ceux qui sont les acteurs de
terrain et en annonçant des choses très
difficiles à mettre en place et et tous
ceux qui qui ont des enfants à l'école
donc vous avez refusé le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale et c'est donc
Nicole Boubé qui prendrait le poste à la
place d'Amélie oua casterra c'est ce
qu'on dit mais de le le euh et c'est pas
la seule question cette question que
j'évoquais de
euh comment on
échappe à la à la bureaucratisation
complète à la à la pape race de tout
instant comment on fait pour que les
gens se sentent plus libres et plus
épanouis ou qu'il soit qu'il soit à
Toulon qu'il soit à Toul par le
gouvernement depuis depuis quelques
années ne dit pas le
contraire qu'est-ce qui fait que il y a
48 heur vous étiez prêt à entrer et que
là vous nêtes plus prêt j'étais prêt à
entrer parce que j'étais persuadé que on
pouvait changer de méthode à l'éducation
nationale pas la méthode récente des des
5 ou qu derniers mois de de Gabriel Atal
mais la méthode qui pendant de qui
depuis 20 ans ou 25 ans on fait que euh
le monde de l'éducation est désespéré et
que les résultats sont
désespérants que que que que nous en
arrivons à être le pays le plus en
retard de tous les pays semblables dans
le monde développé que le j'étais
ministre de l'éducation comme vous savez
il y a longtemps quand j'ai quitté le
ministère de l'Éducation le niveau des
élèves de 6e était le niveau des élèves
de 4e aujourd'hui mais ça ça pardon mais
Gabriel Attal qui était ministre de
l'Éducation il y a 5 mois dit exactement
la même chose et av avait présenté un
plan avec lequel manifestement vous
deviez vous sentir en consonance
puisquil a de jour vous étiez prêts à
entrer oui c'est pas je n'étais pas là
pour appliquer euh des
plans mais d'un ministre deéducation qui
est devenu premier ministre quand même
et qui aurait été votre premier ministre
oui et et et j'ai les meilleures
relations du monde avec les gens avec
qui je travaille Gabriel Atal hier vous
l'avez eu au téléphone oui bien sûr ça
s'est bien passé euh tout à fait
courtoisement amicalement mais est-ce
que
çaatt quand même que que qu'on vous a
même qu'il vous a même proposé le
ministère des armées c'est la vérité je
disais donc euh cette grande crise là
avec les deux secteurs au moins deux il
y en a beaucoup plus au moins deux
secteurs qui sont pour moi euh les les
les absès de fixation euh de de la crise
qu'onit il y en a d'autres la santé est
un absè de fixation je sais pas qui va
être ministre de la Santé tout ça c'est
c'est étrange le euh ces absès de F
attends non non non non non je réponds à
la question précise de Jérôme chapui euh
et on me dit on vous on vous propose de
prendre le ministre des Armées le
ministère des armées c'est le seul
secteur à mes yeux c'est le seul secteur
qui va à peu près bien en tout cas qui
relève les défis dans lequel nous sommes
c'est la c'est la c'est le c'est le
résultat de la politique suivie depuis 5
ans et je n'allais pas me donner le
ridicule d'aller
marcher sur les plat de bandes d'autres
ministres ou d'autres
personnalités dans dans le dans le
secteur qui je considère est à peu près
le seul exemple de de remise à niveau et
de remise en vocation de notre pays
juste c'est un détail mais en faisant
état de cette conversation entre le
Premier ministre et vous vous mettez par
ailleurs un peu le bazar dans l'équipe
gouvernementale actuelle vous savez les
ministres il savent très bien que leurs
portefeuilles sont
que qui peut arriver que qu'on vous
demande d'en changer mais mais vous vous
avez utilisé un mot fort hier devant vos
rou vous avez parler d'une démarche
d'humiliation vous avez vous vous êtes
senti humilié été rapporté par un
certain nombre d'entre eux ça a été
rapporté mais je suis pas sûr que ces
mots étaient les miens
mais une majorité c'est la prise en
compte de plusieurs sensibilité et de
plusieurs courants c'est comme ça qu'on
a gagné en 2017 et qu'on a gagné en 2022
ça n'est pas certains qui décident et
d'autres qui sont marginalisés le le
vous vous sentez marginalisé non c'est
pas de moi comprenez-moi c'est sympa
mais c'est pas de moi qui s'agit je ne
suis pas là je fais pas carrière je ne
candidate pas je ne suis candidat qu'à
une seule chose c'est un lien avec le
pays dans ses profondeurs pour
identifier ce qui va mal et le résoudre
mais quand même François parmi ceux qui
nous écoutent ce matin et même dans la
sphère politique certains peuvent se
dire il est en train de faire un caca
nerveux il a pas eu ce qu'il veut et
donc du coup je suis pas sûr queoule mé
je ne suis pas sûr que cette expression
soit à la fait un caprice s vous si vous
voulez oui je je sais bien qu'on peut
toujours caricaturer les
choses je pourrais caricaturer les
médias je le fais pas non mais je parle
de on parle pas seulement de votre image
on parle aussi de comment dire la
question de l'image de la politique
excusez-moi si vous trouvez que ça va
bien depuis des années et que la
situation d'aujourd'hui elle est
encourageante et que on voit bien si
vous trouvez que les extrêmes reculent
moi je trouve qu'il progresse et que
c'est le symptôme des difficultés que
nous rencontrons mais pardon mais ce que
vous nous dites là ce matin j'imagine
que vous l'avez dit à Emmanuel Macron
depuis plusieurs semaines depuis
plusieurs mois depuis plusieurs années
DEPS anné depuis plusieurs années et
alors là vous en êtes arrivé à un point
de rupture ça y est c'est terminé un
point de rupture je j'essaie
de recentrer de réorienter
la politique suivie pas la politique
suivie dans les mesures mais la
politique suivie dans la manière dont on
s'adresse au pays le le le que les que
les Français alors Gabriel àal de ce
point de vue il apporte quelque chose il
a son jeune âge et il a c'est une figure
nouvelle mais le le profond de la
composition de ce que nous sommes en
train de faire ça signifie que les
Français
euh ils sont loin de tout ça et moi je
voudrais qu'ils soi près de tout ça je
pense que nous sommes je je sais bien
que c'est difficile à entendre je pense
que nous sommes à un point
de de grave inquiétude pour ne pas dire
de non retour je pense que la que la
situation se dégrade continuellement
vous voyez la situation du commerce
extérieur par exemple non mais pardon
François Baou on connaît l'état du pays
non le prier ministre aussi don il est
question ce matin c'est votre situation
politique à vous à celle du MoDem aussi
est-ce qu' est-ce que le modem est
toujours allié de d'Emmanuel Macron de
renaissance de la majorité ce que vous
faites ce matin vous comprenez que ça a
une portée politique ça une portée
politique heureusement sans probablement
je le ferais pas si si je si je pensais
que tout va bien et qu'il n'y a plus
qu'à laisser filer moi je suis tout à
fait heureux dans ma vie le MoDem a une
responsabilité comme la majorité il est
membre de la majorité pour reconstruire
le pays ça changera pas ça il est membre
de la majorité pour corriger ou pour
soigner les les extrêmes difficultés que
nous rencontrons ces extrêmes
difficultés là les orientations prises
doivent les prendre en compte le vous
voyez bien que c'est pas le cas vous
dites vousmême alors gographique
l'équilibre politique l'équilibre
d'inspiration tout cela doit être prise
en compte mais vous voyez bien que c'est
pas le cas ils vous l'ont dit hier par
rapport à l'éducation nationale par
rapport à l'aménagement du territoire
quand vous savez ça il faut en tirer des
conclusions je pense que vous écoutez la
phrase que vous avez dite la phrase que
vous avez dit c'est ils vous ont dit
hier que ça n'était pas le cas c'est ça
que vous dites c'est ce qu'on a compris
en tout cas de ce que vous dites depuis
tout à l'heure c'est comme ça qu'on
interte ce que nous exement pas
gouvernement et donc pour moi il faut
corriger les choses de manière que ceux
qui ont le
souci de l'unité du pays de
l'homogénéité du pays et de la prise en
compte de la base dans les dans les
réformes ils a il soi entendu dans dans
les équilibre à construire françois b
coupe on laisse passer le fil info on
vous retrouve juste après 8h53 sopie et
830 France Info Jérôme chapui sal
toujours avec françoisou le président du
MoDem vous disiez juste avant le fil
info que ceux qui pensent comme vous
doivent avoir une importante au
gouvernement concrètement vous voulez
combien de ministres dans le prochain
gouvernement je ne fais pas de
marchandage et je ne suis pas
là comme comme au marché au bestiaux non
je pense qu'il faut une place reconnue
mais ce qui compte le plus c'est que il
se sentent que ce que ces courants
politiques nous ne sommes pas le seul
dans la majorité il y a bien d'autres
sensibilités qui voudrait qu'on trouve
un meilleur équilibre mais parlez
franchement François Baou en fait
concrètement c'est quoi que vous êtes
dit lors du dernier remanement il y a eu
trop de de de débauchage à droite et
donc là il faut rééquilibrer c'est c'est
je sais bien que c'est l'habitude de
mettre de mettre des étiquettes de cet
ordre là ça n'est pas ce que je ressens
je ressens que le pays a besoin de plus
de compréhension politique de ce qui se
passe à la base et de moins de
technocratie gestionnaire ça va c'est
clair bon assez mal de votre soutien
prochain au au gouvernement qui va être
complété dans les heures qui viennent
mon soutien ne se marchande pas à
condition que soit entendu
la l'inquiétude que un très grand nombre
de Français ressentent qui se traduit
dans tous les sondages et qui se traduit
dans des intentions de vote qui sont
pour
moi pas normales alors soyons très
concret donc oui vous êtes encore dans
la majorité oui nous sommes membre à
part entière de la majorité qui veut
reconstruire le pays oui vous voterez
les textes du prochain gouvernement
dirigé par Gabriel Atal je j'ignore
quels sont ces textes et je ne prends
pas ce type de d'engagement général
avant de les lire oui vous soutiendrez
la prochaine ministre ou le prochain
ministre de l'éducation que ce soit
Nicole Boubet ou quelqu'un d'autre oui
s'ils font des choses bien si si si on
prend en compte
le l'incroyable capacité
de de d'inventivité de de créativité de
de pédagogie qu'il y a dans le pays si
on le prend en compte la base ceux qui
sont dans les
classes le le ministère de l'Éducation
nationale ça ne se joue pas dans des
enceintes ministérielles seulement ça se
joue dans les classes est-ce que les
classes aujourd'hui sont prises en
compte est-ce que les enseignants ont le
sentiment que le le ce qu'on leur
demande va va résoudre les problèmes
qu'il rencont c'est exactement vous avez
dit François Baou hier je ne rentrerai
pas dans le gouvernement si Emmanuel
Macron vous écoute ce matin si Gabriel
Atal vous écoute ce matin d'ailleurs on
n doute pas s'il change d'avis et vous
dit en fait on est d'accord avec avec ce
que tu dis François rejoins-nous vous y
allez
ou alors c'est totalement la porte
fermée ben vous comprenez bien que que
que
que c'est pas le chemin que ça prend
cette fois vous écartez puisque il y a
de jours vous disiez je n'écarte jamais
rien là cette fois ça vous l'écartez la
décision que j'ai prise elle veut dire
évidemment que que que que le rôle que
que j'ai en politique je ne le jouerai
pas à l'intérieur du gouvernement est-ce
qu'elle veut dire autre chose au-delà
pour 2027 aussi
oui je pense que l'enjeu de 2027 c'est
précisément que qu'on arrive à
réconcilier la France qui se bat en bas
avec la France qui décide en
haut je pense que c'est très important
que c'est une crise qui est qui vient de
loin de décennies et cette crise
là il faut que 2027 et les années qui
précèdent servent à montrer un chemin
pour en sortir et ces chemins c'est vous
qui allez le montrer en 2027 ben je n'ai
jamais renoncé à aucun des devoirs qui
sont les miens aucune des
responsabilités qui sont les miennes je
suis un élu de province la province la
plus lointaine de France je sais ce que
vivent tous ceux qui observent venant
d'en haut des directives qui sont
souvent en contradiction avec ce qui se
passe sur le terrain et les blocages qui
viennent de là vous êtes à de dire
qu'Emmanuel Macron est totalement
déconnecté là je non non
j'ai j'ai assez d'estime pour le
président de la République je dis que le
le le mouvement que nous sommes en train
de vivre c'est assez largement des
dérives corrigeons-les corrigeons-les
avec la majorité corrigeons-les avec le
futur gouvernement mais corrigeons-les
et prenons-les en
compte ne jouons pas la sururdité euh ne
jouons pas le bandeau sur les yeux en
considérant que il suffit de continuer
comme on a fait jusqu'à maintenant
suffit pas de quand ce 8 février 2024
vous preniez date très clairement pour
l'élection présidentielle de
2027 c'est pas moi qui prends date pour
l'élection présidentielle
c'est c'est le pays je sais pas si je
sais pas si vous
voyez ouvrez les yeux sur ce que nous
sommes en train de vivre ça va finir où
ce truc cette pardon ce truc vous parlez
du quinen d' Emmanuel Macron non non je
parle de la politique française telle
qu'elle est conduite depuis de longues
années et sans doute des que vous
soutenez depuis 7 ans oui que je que je
soutiens que j'ai contribué à mettre en
place parce que avant il y avait d'une
d'une certaine manière un échec qui est
constaté aujourd'hui par tout le monde
oui mais je ne laisserai pas dériver les
choses sans rien dire juste d'un mot et
ce sera oui non François Baayou parce
qu'on est on est contre par le temps
vous regrettez votre soutien Emmanuel
Macron depuis 2017 jamais jamais jamais
parce que imaginez ce que nous aurions
rencontré si Emmanuel Macron n'avait pas
étaé élu et s'il ne s'était pas créé ce
nouveau paysage que nous vivons mais je
dis je ne laisserai pas faire un certain
nombre de dérives qui sont fondées sur
l'ignorance par les responsables du
sommet de ce que vivent les Français à
la base merci beaucoup François baayerou
président du MoDem d'avoir été l'invité
de France Info ce matin